la deux chevaux c'est quand même c'est
quand même bien c'est sympa lorsque la
deux chevaux et présenté au salon de
l'auto en 1948 le but de citroën n'est
pas de faire une voiture sympa mais une
voiture pas cher le constructeur on fera
surtout une voiture mythique plus de 5
millions de deux chevaux seront
fabriqués avec pourtant à l'origine un
cahier des charges très simple et très
champêtre comme le voulait son créateur
pierre boulanger pour illustrer le
confort qu'ils souhaitaient du véhicule
il a dit je veux que l'on puisse mettre
quatre personnes à l'intérieur de la
voiture qu'elle puisse rouler à 50
km/heure et que l'on puisse poser à
l'arrière un panier deux pleins et qu'à
cette vitesse là aucun des zones casse
même en passant dans un champ labouré
rien de bien attrayant en somme mais
avec sa bouille sympathique et son prix
modique
la deux chevaux va être adopté par les
français ils en font une voiture à vivre
simple et pratique tellement pratique
que les français la choisissent pour
partir à l'aventuré
parmi ces jeunes explorateurs un certain
jacques séguéla alors qu'il n'est pas
encore devenu le célèbre publicitaire
qu'on connaît il effectue avec un ami un
tour du monde au volant d'une dodge qu à
la fin des années 50
cette espèce de douceur ce moelleux deux
de ses sièges
on est lentement bercé et ça porte à la
connaissance de l'autre et des autres
connaissances des autres et
connaissances en mécanique aussi sur la
route de kaboul en 1970 c'est l'art de
la débrouille joyeuse le châssis arrière
dont les bras sont pas tendues pas
étonnant donc après tant de bons et
loyaux services
toujours dans la bonne humeur la deux
chevaux surnommé l' de dèche entre dans
la mythologie française
la rousse était une des routes très très
raide et alors pour bien adhérer
maintenance asseyez sur le capot et on
pouvait monter quand je me sens gala lys
jusqu'à la montagne la tanière de
chevaux sur des usines en 1990
quarante deux ans de production un
record de longévité en france pour une
voiture vraiment pas comme les autres
[Musique]
et sachez que la deux chevaux des pas
une voiture c'est un art de vivre
[Musique]